crazy ghost children a violin concert
and pass me some of that morphine
because we have another episode of from
where more questions are posed than
answered if you're new to these videos
this is not a recap rather a deep dive
into all the new Clues and theories from
the episode as always I've left time
stamps below so you can check out all
the topics I'll be covering now hang up
your Talisman because here we go well
that no good Randall is learning what
it's like to sleep by himself in the bus
with the old granny monster from season
1 making another return the odd thing
about these monsters is that they all
wear outfits from the 50s and 60s I mean
forgive me if I'm wrong but I don't
think we've seen any monsters in 80s 90s
or 2000s gar it's like these guys are
stuck in time the car's Victor show Jade
also seemed to be from when he arrived
in the 1970s with Victor even stating
there are older cars that were here
before him but none of these cars seem
to be from after the 1970s the this
makes me think of the Stone etchings
from Tabitha's dream in season one the
earliest one dates to 1506 and the
latest
1978. 1978 seems to be the latest date
that some sort of major event happened
perhaps this relates to what Christopher
did to the town more on that in a bit at
the end of the episode we see Randall
carving something out of wood honestly
it's a bit too early to tell what he's
carving it looks like the beginnings of
a cross but Randall doesn't strike me as
an overly religious guy but when you
have monsters around who knows at long
last we get the name of the mysterious
man in Victor's Polaroid this is
Christopher a man Victor says was well
liked by everyone in town however as
soon as he started seeing this symbol he
started to go crazy we know that Jade
has also started to see this symbol even
seeing a vision of Christopher and his
notebook filled with scribbles of it is
this hinting that Jade may be following
in Christopher's footsteps later in the
episode we learned that Victor's mother
told him to hide One Night in a place
Christopher couldn't find him it's
implied that this is the seller we saw
young Victor emerge out of in season 1
episode 4. there he finds everyone in
town has been disemboweled so it appears
Victor's mother knew something bad was
going to happen and had Victor hide to
save him just what role Christopher
played in all this is unknown but he
definitely would have needed help Victor
tells him there are things out there
that make people do bad things and we've
already seen how Sarah was swayed to
kill Ethan Jade also takes a good long
look at Christopher's car making me
wonder if he'll be back to investigate
it further and just a reminder if you
like these types of videos please make
sure to like And subscribe every little
bit helps the channel out well it looks
like the show is definitely setting up
Sarah in Elgin even after Elgin finds
out Sarah is this killer he still helps
her pick up her things after Kenny
breaks her ornament when he notices he's
never seen her before he says quote I
would have noticed you both Sarah and
Elgin have some sort of connection with
this place with Sarah experiencing
visions and elgin's dreams perhaps the
two can work together and figure out a
way out of here Ethan has his own little
Arc this episode first being afraid that
Sarah the woman who tried to kill her is
freely able to roam the town and then
mustering the strength to confront her
this was after his dad brought up the
hero in his favorite story The
chromonaco in season 1 episode 6 Ethan
describes the story in which the kroman
uncle finds the lonely dragons Cavern
filled with stuff no one wanted but
inside there was a map that would make
the chronicle not lost anymore could
this cave be the same one Tabitha and
Victor traveled through in episode 1.
it's also filled with stuff people might
not want and also contains a map the
theme of quests have been brought up all
throughout this series with Ethan
stating quote when you're on a quest you
have to face the scary things that's how
you take their power away so you're
saying if I go out at night and tell
these monsters I'm not scared of them
they'll go away I won't be trying Theory
anytime soon Boyd went on a quest at the
end of season 1 which made him face
scary things and when he returned the
monsters didn't notice him in the woods
I wonder if there's a connection there
last episode we saw Muriel checking out
the hospital's drug cabinet well it
seems she has an addiction to
painkillers as Tilly the fanny pack lady
drops off her bottle of morphine which
Muriel promptly enjoys we never find out
exactly what Tilly is suffering from
perhaps cancer but it gives some added
context to why she was on that bus and
why she went dancing in the rain if she
was dying it makes sense she's spending
the rest of her money at the racetracks
and her dance could be her enjoying what
last bit of life she has now since the
show is from the creators of lost
spoiler warning for the next 15 seconds
they might be pulling a John Locke in
that this place may have cured Tilly of
her ailment just like the island allowed
Jon to walk again but just how Tilly
would have known she was cured and her
also saying that she may need help at
administering the morphine later makes
this Theory weak Tabitha takes her son's
puzzle set the one that looks similar to
The Rock Cairn found in the caves and
sets it up outside the entrance I'm not
exactly sure what she was hoping to
accomplish here but I found it
interesting the children emerge from the
forest and not the cave they all seem to
chant the same word on kui over and over
again at the time of this writing I
didn't have access to the subtitles to
get the exact spelling to see if it's a
foreign language or perhaps an anagram a
particular interest or how the children
are drawn towards her jacket the same
jacket she picked up in the second-hand
clothes shed with her daughter two
episodes ago both the puzzle game and
this jacket were from people who came
prior to them so it's possible these
objects have some sort of connection and
I don't know about you guys but I
thought the Cliffhanger to this episode
was pretty weak we have buoyed
experiencing those worms again but it
didn't give us any new clues or changed
the plot in any way he's coming to see
10 likely to explain why her husband's
murderer is roaming freely regardless
I'm hoping we get more answers as the
show just keeps pumping out more
questions without resolving the ones
that have already been posed but now I
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below thanks for
watching and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
these people are [__]
foreign